okay today I'm going to talk to you
about something in B one called plants
growth hormones now what these are these
growth hormones are in plants they are
these things that allow the plant to
grow so in the chute of a plant the
auctions are made near the tip now these
auctions these hormones are just
chemical messengers that allow the shoot
to grow so they encourage growth when
they're produced in the tip they diffuse
backwards they diffuse backwards and
encourage growth so they encourage
elongation of the chute and for it to
grow now when we have a light introduced
so let's say this was a light bulb right
here the light actually causes some of
the auxins to break down so the auxins
will accumulate on the other side on the
dark side from the light this causes
this side to grow faster and this side
to grow slower because this side is
growing quickly because it's got a
higher concentration of aux-in and
because this side is growing slowly
because there's a lower concentration of
aux-in
because it's been broken diet down by
the light we can see that this this
chute is going to start to grow towards
the light now this is advantageous to
the plant because if it gets more light
it can get more light energy for
photosynthesis so therefore to be able
to make more glucose now this phenomenon
of growing towards the light is called
positive because it's towards the light
and then photo tropism photo to do with
light tropism meaning growing or growing
so growing towards the light now a
classic experiment they like to show in
exams is this here so let's imagine
we've got three different plants in
three different conditions ok so my
first one
is just completely normal nothing's been
done to this one at all this one here
has had the top of the chute cut off now
this one here
it hasn't been damaged but they've put a
foil hat on it that doesn't allow any
light to to reach this chute so what
they then save they'd like to say let's
see saying this light bulb now is shown
in this way so the light is coming that
way within our experiment what would
happen to each of these and why so what
would happen to this one on the left is
the light would break down the Orcas ins
on this side so we'd have an
accumulation of auxins
on the dark side that will cause this
side to grow quickly and this side to
grow slowly which means this one would
start to grow towards the light positive
phototropism now this one here because
it's have the chute cut off the top of
the chute cut off it's not producing any
oxygen at all because it's not producing
any options at all it will not grow
remember auxins are plant hormones plant
growth hormones that help the plant to
grow so without them it's not going to
grow now this one because it hasn't had
the chute cut off it's still going to
grow because it's still going to be
producing auxins however this one
because we've it's wearing it's it's got
the foil kind of hats on it this one
isn't going to be affected by the light
which means that auxins are just going
to diffuse backwards down the chute and
it's just going to encourage growth this
way so this one would just go to road
directly upwards so just a recap plant
growth hormones help plants to grow the
specific name of them or haven't even
written it down yet actually is pork
since that's the name of the plant
growth hormone they accumulate auxins
accumulate in the dark side so away from
the light and they encourage growth and
positive phototropism mean
growing towards the light thank you